go uh but here's my thing I love meat
it's great I've taken I've taken time
off of it before I did two years of just
pescetarian really yeah yeah dude which
is just you know fish and vegetables I
did that for two years once that's the
longest that I've done that oh I'll do
it you grow up pose
I'm sorry sir what was that right
nothing yeah but you did you shared some
sort of joke and then you laughed super
and finally like did you pump your fist
oh okay well anyway I was eating seafood
and vegetables mostly
one more time please what was that
nothing man keep going keep going it's
all good it's all good
yeah what were you saying I avoided most
bottom-feeders a shrimp was probably a
little too fatty things like clams and
oysters I didn't have much mostly white
fish is a white fish and a your period
excuse me friend what did you what did
you make some sort of now what we use
mention of no that's more is that some
of that bro humor same I just be walking
out Lao what's good what are you talking
about I was just telling you about my
eating habits because you wanted to have
a real you so having you lived on yeah
but you but then you said first of all
you said listening I heard you say [ __ ]
dress and period I heard you say that
huh I
I heard you say [ __ ]
yeah dress and period was in
menstruation okay I don't know what do
you mean I don't know I'm talking well
if you want to have a real conversation
having a real conversation and other
times I actually just you know went
vegetarian for a little Bob but I felt
like was near you you know what is what
what whoa hey hey no no do it do it
don't do it
Hey
that's my penis I can measure distance
and you would kick and you to overstep
and then your [ __ ] face with you and
I would go right back yeah yeah I go
boop boop boop I understand combinations
boop boop yes whack and you go meet me
and [ __ ] your pants how did you he's all
[ __ ] heart yep there they are
laughter I got like truth when I got
stage I was like let me let us be in
your movie be in our movie we love you
so movie hey what movie I heard you're
what movie you doing you doing man quest
yet for years you've been talking about
shooting man well I got busy well yeah
but what about man quest I got busy
though you know sorry but you doesn't
talking about man quest for years yeah I
know man and I'm still work I just know
about man my own pace about a guy who
become goes from boy to man you know
that's something I'm working on boy to
man yeah and I don't need you i I don't
need you mocking my process I'm not
mocking your [ __ ] first of all you
don't have a process to mom
hey I know no you don't you don't have a
process to me yeah
you just [ __ ] I go through life the
Goldbergs and then you whoa this is you
this is you getting this is you
carefully they're like oh hold on I'm
gonna tell you I don't I need to talk
about your process alright okay I'll let
me tell you about your pencil and be
honest I'm always respectful and honest
that is like someone who's like but I
can feel she's what you do you go like
hey honestly let me tell you so you're
gonna preface this by saying honestly
which means the rest of what you're
saying is [ __ ] that's you bryan
callen chin yeah here's here's you
you're doing the Goldbergs it's going
great and they're like oh we're thinking
of spinning this character off when
we're thinking about doing in school and
blah blah blah and here's how you add to
that and you fall into it you're [ __ ]
that's your entire [ __ ] career Oh
ain't I wrote down my dream board and I
can show it to you I bet your dream
board is a cork board and your
bathroom and it's got three pictures on
it yeah there's a [ __ ] a canoe in a
lake there's a [ __ ] pair of suede
shoes and a little red chair okay why
that's what you got well why would all
that be on my train board that's all you
got going on up here
I got a canoe in a lake what yes I feel
like I'm a canoe on a giant lake no
you're like I want to go out in nature
when we're in nature and then you wanna
then you want in the you like nature so
nature is one of my goals yeah [ __ ]
going out in nature which is someone you
just you're gonna be hiking out there
amongst the the roots and rocks and you
go and fall in the water and you wish
you had a canoe you better shut up or
I'm gonna [ __ ] punch you and I'd love
to see it don't I didn't flinch okay
well you know what that means
listen man don't I do and I come home
told you not to defend your side oh how
to defend myself Jesus actually works oh
I came out of me man you scared me you
just got as a serious coward yeah okay
you just got at it as a fart fart and
coward right that's not good for my rep
no it's why'd you do that because I
didn't know that you'd be a fart fart
and coward if I came at you yeah but I
want look at me adjusting in this
[ __ ] chair me now is this the part
all right now hey everybody welcome to
the ma'am fighter not here look you know
maybe we got a great show for you we're
gonna be talking about some mixed
martial arts all right well lifestyle
section yeah Xuan Xuan all right
lifestyle section and it's sexual all
right okay gallant
all right to knowledge all right well
listen I get this some shop hey we'll
have fun taking my spots they have
Kallen tried to talk politics or
something
oh poor boring you have my permission to
sock him in his old fat dick now I go
hey and then sassa goes do you mean to
say that when people approach today's
wide media landscape seeking political
coverage and opinions that they
shouldn't count t fat K as a clear
option I mean how are people going to
get their news if old windbag McGrew
MacGregor jeté Tom something he heard
doesn't play more on Anderson Cooper
with your listeners whatever dude it's
your show I'm like will and then and
then shot goes will for president callum
for sucking dick really mature and then
I go you got to take this back guys and
then they get this from well in quotes
hi my name is Jimmy and I love the
fighter and a kid when I look for
opinions I can trust today's fast-paced
news cycle I listen to Bryan Callen or
one of my dad's friends who does
whatever for a living and watches
Hannity sometimes then I get Bryan I'm
taking a [ __ ] and get an uber give you
an ETA soon yeah the airport
you wanted to show up I showed up that's
my commitment to your list at this sort
of [ __ ] people're it's crazy that people
are deal about you know about you
because you're you're more keep pushing
the mic into my face it's super
disrespect you are very more around
that's four times I'm already not a
figure you've got I bet you've got not a
fifty dude don't you like a hot blonde
hair like stormy day October my junk in
your English because you're Dutch you're
[ __ ] stars I'll tell you what they're
gonna do they're gonna have to grow like
you know they're gonna have to take her
earlobes up so you get the kind of the
eyelid surgery that I want oh I don't
think so I think the one you want you
want to take a little more off skin I
want to take a little skin off the
droopy skin I'm Tina that's good [ __ ]
makes you look like a fighter but I am a
fighter or the fighter
Podcast fighter no you're not fighting
you hop around a gym mat with guys you
pay you pay them hey I'm a fighter
here's $100 jump around with me for an
hour so I can punch things well mmm
Viator well you got my you know what you
know what kind of you know what kind of
fighter you are the fighter who has a
hundred dollars to give to someone
grounds come hey would you hold bad for
me to punch yes I will how much that
will be $100 luggage here it is pull
your chute wheel because the walls come
that's me heading right to the ground
like a bomb no I'm not worried I'm not
worried
you got really upset dude [ __ ] talked
about this for too much or that for too
much I'm perfectly fine to let you drive
yeah I was just Honda sending them no I
was thinking about something that I saw
on TV no you're already trying to be the
alpha male on this no no I don't that's
that [ __ ] either comes naturally or it
doesn't okay
don't [ __ ] oh I'm an alpha - so
that's the thing
don't yeah but don't look we're not you
know what because I don't like your body
label because I'm not gonna sit up - I'm
not afraid to fight you and I'll say
that right now you you're sitting oh you
gotta you need your no wonder you don't
acknowledge mine to get you up don't
tell a big man ass like me okay I got a
big fat man oh god yeah what what do you
do with that what my big fat man you
ever have a girl be honest with me you
ever have a woman because I know you see
you get you get girls sometimes that
like their big man they like a big man
you ever have a woman get-get except
just work work your ass work my I know
what I asked you yeah I've had women
like stand on my ass yeah what else you
ever have a girl just need it like dough
yeah I need it like dough and ass just
get down and need it yeah or you know
hold the edge of that I have a very
regal looking bed so the head the
headboard is very regal and it goes up
there's there's there's leather there's
wood very regal no wait that burned down
man they'll hold it and then they'll
just you know geisha my ass with your
case vacation if I get to relax
then you know a little size five now as
I get older even though I look 35 and we
know that and I look like all the time
yep you look 35 and you move like you're
35 you look like you've liked it 35
that's important because because because
you don't know what that's about but I
my body does whatever I tell it to you
look like a weathered 35 year old would
you put up the picture of the singer of
The Pogues Ian McKellen I know you're
dying miss Ellen yeah it is and I and
I'm a fan of Shane MacGowan whatever
sounded these pictures were olive these
are all poems - an McGowan yeah he's a
fanatic roughly 35 years of it he had
some problem you look like yeah he's got
a few there he is
so he you know he mixes him up he has a
Shandy with breakfast he's got she was
with when it comes to he's had some big
well he's been drinking yeah and heroin
in McGowan he's a fan of heroin he's a
Scot again he's a Scot he's got no
[ __ ] teeth yeah but he's 13 he's
probably 27 years old there so I could
see how you could I saw heavy driver in
a think it was CBGB's in New York City
and he came out so [ __ ] up but goddamn
I love his music yeah a real [ __ ]
poet yeah look at those teeth Shane
Shane was a bad teeth it was a real bad
tooth so anyway you're 35 looking he and
you know why Steve kept falling he was
just fall flat on his face after getting
talking about his teeth the rotten cuz
he's drinking all right man all he's
doing is drinking he needs to be would
fall flat on his face he had these
perfect pearly whites and then he fell
on the cobblestone street
I died at Meijer and he's not it doesn't
it doesn't tell it is how you do the
internet this is how you do the new
media get the lie to involve everybody
you got to get the like do it for the
gram bro do for the grand Bryan's
Instagram is the only Instagram that is
a full-length television show yeah Wow
yeah every what do we got one minute
here's one minute all right dude and no
didn't delete talked about this that it
was video fill in a minute I've heard it
I had to do that one where he just sent
me that Hilaire I didn't [ __ ] see it
shut the [ __ ] up I'm racing Chris we
know and your audience knows of course
and
a specific instrument you've seen this
one yeah I've seen all those the last
one I looked more like my nose you know
lore Bubba what's getting very big in
older Bubba man right there your here's
the Frog in life the pelican if they
give you if Instagram increased it to
two and a half minutes your videos are
between you do 13 minutes he would do 13
minutes he would just talk until and
it's like you know and now I'm heading
over to and that's how they stop because
he's just talking until it ends you're
the only person who also uses the the
the camera in it and just records right
on the app and then send he opens
Instagram come on man talks into it
bring him in there and then he hits send
I hate being unfair my eyes I gotta get
my eyes pulled up a little bit yeah
let's I would like to one set up some
eyeballs I mean I'm not met your
eyebrows though bro it's the one
fantastic and smash your nose with that
oh now so go on good luck cuz I come I
have a good head movement now listen
I'll take three shots you can miss the
first two you are not gonna all right
what's this thing you catch that in the
heart I'll answer back to and catch that
and the [ __ ] head let's add up with
one hand don't [ __ ] threaten to cave
my head and threatening anything what is
your story
all right you historical ignoramus
staged this alright in touch with me the
man who made this yeah wonderful artist
and he's gonna make another one for you
cuz I'm gonna break that into two
perfect pieces on your nose
[ __ ] the end this is the problem you got
a truss Brendan just let him do whatever
the [ __ ] he's gonna do alright
by the way though the only reason you're
sitting here in this place right now is
because of Brendan so you know you take
that back I have proof positive why it's
the only reason why because you and I
had a podcast for years okay and I'm
still doing it guess where I'm doing it
yeah and
same [ __ ] house yeah you're right
Brendan will rent the space he'll have a
artist coming to beat this he'll get
chairs yeah he's a nut right in
and over my house where we do the 10
minute podcast by the way tune in to the
10 minute podcast every Tuesday and
Thursday it's a 10 minute show myself
and writer producers Chad Kultgen and
Tommy Bloch it's very fun you have the
absolute funniest irreverent and
thoughtful intelligent guys I know a
little bit of a departure now the way it
used to go now but I'll tell you it
still smells like your farts and I'm
smoking these foamies and mike and job
is that job as a businessman yeah he's a
nut we're we're and also he has that he
has that that you and I don't have he
has that pro-athlete sustained intensity
that's that sustained ferocity
yeah and that need to dominate other
podcasts yeah that's interesting by the
way I do want to talk about this when
well whatever you know I'll say it now
excuse me Bob drink too much water I
just need to wash that water down now I
got to watch those burps down without
water doc hold on it's a vicious cycle
I'm a nickel the love of God don't drink
another glass and tell you this right
now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue oh good what's gonna happen what
are you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]